معنا من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي الياس حنا اهلا بك عميد
الياس وابدا معك من العاجل الذين نقلناه
قبل قليل عن مستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
ميخائيل الذي قال ان الحرب داخل الاراضي
الروسيه بدات بالفعل اي منعطف تدخله الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا بهذا التطور
سهام هي حده ووتيره
الهجومات على الاراضي الروسيه وهذا الامر
يؤشر الى مرحله جديده يعني اليوم عندما
نتحدث عن بيل جورود هي كانت اصلا منذ
بدايات الحرب قاعده لوجستيه مهمه لمنطقه
خركاب وازيون نتحدث عن كريسندار هي ايضا
منطقه لوجستيه وخلفيه مهمه تعبر جسر كرش
الى شبه جزيره قرم لدعم القوات الروسيه ان
كان فيزا او حتى في خرسون فاذا نحن نتحدث
عن مرحله عزل لوجستي او اضعاف الامكانيات
للجيش الروسي اللوجستيه هذا عدا زرع
الفوضى في الداخل الروسي عبر المسيرات على
الكريم او حتى على موسكو فاذا نحن امام
مرحله جديده يطلق عليها سهام ما يسمى
جراوند يعني انت تحضرين الارض للمرحله
والمعركه القادمه عميد الياس بالنسبه لم
الرئاسه وهو يعني تصريح رسمي اوكراني
بالاشاره الى حجم المسيرات الذي وصل الى
الاراضي الروسيه وتعلم ان المواقف الغربيه
وخاصه الولايات المتحده ابدت واكدت عدم
موافقتها على هذه العمليات العسكريه التي
تدخل النطاق الجغرافي
لروسيا هل معنى ذلك ان هنالك تحول رسمي
وتبني لهذه العمليات من الجانب الاوكراني
لا بالطبع محمد الهدف دائما هو الجيش
الامريكي او القوات الغربيه النيتو وحتى
امريكا تقول لي اوكرانيا ما نعطيكم من
سلاح بعيد المدى واخرها ستورم شادو لا
يمكن ولا نسمح باستعماله ضد الداخل الروسي
اليوم كل الهجمات الاوكرانيه على روسيا هي
من صناعه اوكرانيه في الداخل وهي من ضمن
استراتيجيه مستقله عن الطلبات الغربيه
وبشكل ان تقول امريكا دائما نحن ضد
الاعتداءات او الهجومات على الداخل
الروسيه ولكن نحن لا يمكن لنا ان نسيطر
على اهداف معينه اذا قصفت اكياف فيجب ان
تهدد موسكو على سبيل المثال هنا الفارق هو
اساسي
هذا تطور الان بانتقال الضربات الى داخل
الروسي كيف سيؤثر على حسابات روسيا الان
واستراتيجيتها في هذه الحرب قبل ايام كان
هناك حديث عن ضروره الاستيلاء على خاركيف
لوقف الضربات على بالقرود هل يمكن لروسيا
التعامل مع كل هذه الضربات الان في عده
مناطق في داخل الروسي
سهام العوده الى خركيف امر صعب حسب جريده
الواشنطن بوست منذ اسبوع نشرت صور جويه من
الاقمار الاصطناعيه تقول ان الواقع الروسي
والجيش الروسي داخل اوكرانيا ياخذ وضعيه
الدفاع وبشكل كامل على طول الجبهه الممتده
لاكثر من 600 كيلو متر اليوم عندما نتحدث
عن استرداد خرقان هذا الامر يتطلب جهد
وهذا الامر ليس متوفر اليوم المسيرات
الاوكرانيه فعلا لا تغير مجرى الحرب هي
الهدف منها زرع الفوضى في الداخل الروسيه
اظهار هشاشه الرئيس بوتين وحتى الدفاعات
الجويه وتثبيت قدر من القوات الروسيه على
الجبهات خاصه في كراش نضال وفي بيلجورود
وبريانس وبالتالي لعدم استعمالها في مكان
اخر وهذا امر يعتبر وكانه خداع ما كما حصل
نتذكر ما حصل في خركاب وخلصون وكانه خداع
في مكان ما للتحضير لمرحله يعني كابتن
نوايا واخفاء النوايا لهجوم قد يحضر في
مرحله لاحقه
شكرا لك عميد الياس حنا المحلل العسكري
والاستراتيجيه كنت معنا من بيروت